- coins tossed simultaneously and - dice
rolled simultaneously are the two
important kinds of probability problems
you will come across in your exams do
not ignore the other types but
understand these two types really well
now think of the number of possibilities
in the first case there are two coins we
may get a head on the first coin and a
head on the other one as well this is
one possibility the other possibility is
that you may get a head on the first
coin and a tail on the other that the
second possibility or we may get a tail
on the first coin and a head on the
other or we may get tails on both the
coins do any more possibilities exist
nope that's it four possibilities in all
now how many possibilities in the second
case rolling two dice together take a
moment and think of the different
possibilities that exist okay we may get
a 1 on each of the dice that's one
possibility we may get a 1 on the first
die and a 2 on the second and so on up
to 1 + 6 6 possibilities until now we
may get a 2 on the first die and 1 on
the second or maybe 2 on both and so on
up to 2 & 6 and there will be 6 such
columns 6 columns and 6 rows
36 possibilities in all you won't have
time in your exams to find all the
possibilities you're pretty much
expected to know this so what kind of
problems appear in the exam let's say we
roll two dice together and we are asked
the probability of getting a sum of six
it means the sum of the numbers that
appear on each die has to be 6 how do we
find this probability we know that the
number of possibilities is 36 but how
many possibilities exist whether sum is
6 1 & 5 is one possibility
1 on the first and 5 on the second and
that makes 5 & 1
another possibility 5 on the first and 1
on the second
the sum is 6 in each case 2 & 4 is also
possibility and 4 n 2 as well and the
last possibility of getting a sum of 6
is 3 on each die 5 ways in which we can
get a sum of 6 out of the total 36
possibilities 5 over 36 is the
probability of getting a sum equal to 6
when two dice are rolled ok here's
another one when two dice are rolled
what is the probability of getting a sum
greater than 3 pause the video and try
it out I am sure most of you have come
up with the right answer but
unfortunately it's not only the answer
but also the amount of time you took
that matters one way is to find the
possibilities that give us a sum greater
than 3 they are 2 & 2 2 & 3 2 & 4 and so
on up to 2 & 6 there's more 3 & 2 3 & 3
and so on up to 3 & 6 you would have
noticed that the list is too long this
was not the best way to go about the
answer think about it this way we have
been asked all possibilities which are
greater than 3 it can also be
interpreted as all possibilities except
the ones less than or equal to 3 they
mean the same so we can write this as 1
minus P of some less than or equal to 3
from all 36 possibilities we are
eliminating the ones which are less than
or equal to 3 but why did we write it
like this
it's because the number of possibilities
we have for less than or equal to 3 is
just 3 one on each 2 on the first and
one on the other one on the first and
two on the second 3 in all that's it we
didn't waste much time this was equal 1
minus 3 over 36 it equals 33 over 36
that's the probability of getting the
sum greater than 3 you would have had to
write down 33 possibilities if you would
have chosen this approach the concept is
simple when the number of possibilities
is large use this approach of
eliminating the smaller set from all the
possibilities
you